sano manjiro better known as just mikey
is probably one of the most interesting
and complex characters from the tokyo
avengers story in this video we will
dive into his extremely interesting life
which will involve going over parts of
his personality past and the
uncontrollable rage that he possesses
once he falls into his so-called dark
impulses
but just before we get into mikey if you
guys are new around here and want to
keep up to date with the latest tokyo
avengers content then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also be sure
to leave a like on the video as it
really helps out with the algorithm and
pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of that
let's get back to the video
so mikey's character is quite a
confusing one there are so many i guess
different outcomes and versions of mikey
that we see throughout the series but
here i'm mainly going to stick to the
younger mikey that we meet at the
beginning of the story and stick with
his development through the past up
until the current arc at the start of
the series mikey is 14 years old and
seems to be an extremely relaxed
carefree chilled out person who would
just walk around like he doesn't have a
care in their world though throughout
even the first few chapters we learned
that yes he can be extremely calm but as
soon as anyone he cares for is put in
any kind of danger like initially with
payan or parchin an absolute beast
awakes whose strength is at least double
of anyone else's we meet throughout the
series this is because he believes
himself to be the foundation of tomen
and of him he wants to build this new
world of delinquents so he has to be
someone strong enough to strike fear
into the soul of any opponent and not
ever crumble otherwise toman would also
crumble along with him in front of other
tomen members mainly the fodder and not
necessarily the vice captains or
captains mikey acts different and his
aura changes to that of what the
majority of everyone else sees around
him he becomes extremely commanding and
always respectfully addresses the gang
in an imposing manner in which all of
the members respect him but still in
some way have a degree of fear towards
him and his immense power mikey is
always concerned with atonement and
wants to with every good fiber in his
body create a new world of delinquents
similar to the era in which his
brother's gang roamed the streets and
dealt with all of their issues
independently from the cops and similar
entities though despite this want to
build an amazing future at heart mikey
is still young and can be easily
corrupted through the use of
manipulation and playing on his wants to
build this new era at almost any means
possible which sadly a majority of the
time results in the unfavorable outcomes
for the original tomen members
also sadly because of a flurry of events
that happen throughout the story mikey
is forced to mature to a mental age much
older than that of his actual age and
although i personally think maki does
somewhat mature he doesn't entirely and
this is simply because he is young his
brain hasn't fully matured and he isn't
26 years old like takamichi in a 14 year
old's body he can't fully understand the
impact that each death takes on his mind
and he isn't old enough to be able to
deal with the grief in a normal way so
he holds it in until there is a catalyst
that results in the blowout of a
lifetime literally this is the
uncontrollable rage that mikey possesses
and it's not necessarily this rage that
contributes to his constant fall into
his dark urges but his utter lack of
guidance not having any kind of father
figure that he could look up to to guide
him in a proper way he had to be looked
after by his older brother who happened
to be involved in gangs which no matter
how you look at it isn't a great example
and because of how he molded himself
after his brother it made him take the
role that everyone would lean on for
help as the leader this in turn with the
grief of constantly losing a loved one
is what triggers the start of his
uncontrollable rage as he will
constantly bash away at people until it
feels as though he has filled the void
in his heart when in all reality all he
has done is make it worse
but this is where people like draken
takamichi and the other tomon guys come
in to solve this issue before it erupts
into something completely out of their
control takamichi himself has even been
told by mikey to snap him back onto the
right path if he seems to go astray not
on those words exactly but in a similar
way to how his brother would have guided
him down the correct path as a
delinquent this is their respective
roles throughout the series and their
moments when mikey is at his worst
takamichi is always there to try and
save or fix the situation
though on timelines where mikey indulges
into his dark impulses it shows that he
grows into someone with an extremely sad
and conflicted mind with an almost split
personality as he goes from his either
extremely charismatic self to in one
instance embracing the violence that he
possesses we find that he would commit
multiple murders and heinous crimes or
would command his members of whatever
faction or group he'd been in charge of
to commit these atrocities for him while
still remaining extremely callous while
he planned out all of it sometimes
completely randomly he would even revert
to hunting and shooting some of his
closest friends then at the same time
he's trying to distance himself from
these friends probably realizing that
the little control he has over his dark
urges is dangerous even going as far as
to try and kill himself after he thinks
that it would be the only way to put an
end to his long sad story and in the
chaos that he had created when he
decided to try and build a new era of
delinquents similar to his brother the
main catalyst for these dark impulses
that maki is constantly subject to is
the loss of a loved one or the suffering
that they may go through these deaths
like the original death of shinichiro
sano mikey's older brother affects him
on a completely different level than
most people he claims that their souls
guide him after their death but in all
honesty i think this is just a coping
mechanism that mikey himself makes up as
he's extremely young when the series
starts at 14 years old and 12 when he
first suffers a massive loss so it would
make sense for this to be a way that
mikey manages with the increasing body
count that is constantly building
throughout the series and like if you've
watched my other video on all the deaths
throughout tokyo revenges you'd realize
that the majority of all the permanent
deaths throughout the series are mainly
of sano manjudo's family taking away his
older brother half sister and adopted
brother along with one of his closest
friends in kesuki baji each of these
deaths though slowly step away at his
emotional state and deteriorate his
overall image though he does his best to
try and act composed or normal the
effect of this ever-involving darkness
is more than mikey can handle himself
this factor of a constantly involving
darkness that grows with each death
throughout the series is what renders
mikey completely vulnerable to people
like kisaki or sansu who may be trying
to subsequently control him so that they
can gain whatever they personally want
through the power and aura of mikey's
name and status and the delinquent world
this is obvious as in each timeline so
far that we have been given mikey has
lost those closest to him and
replacement for people who want to use
and manipulate him hoping that these
people can fill the void in his cold
dark heart
but anyway i hope you've all enjoyed my
video on sanumanjido and possibly even
learnt a little bit about him and how
his dark impulses and his uncontrollable
rage end up always seeming to envelop
him if you are new around here and want
to keep up to date with more content
like this then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video as it really
helps out with the algorithm and pushes
my stuff to a bunch of new amazing
people also be sure to drop a comment
down below with what you all thought
about the video and if you have anything
to add on his dark impulses that i may
have possibly missed but anyway for now
it's been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you all in a above
bye
[Music]
you